En este video trataremos de resolver la ecuación
3 (x + 1) - x = 9, y como siempre te invito a
pausar este video e intentar resolverlo por
tu cuenta. Pero el énfasis de este video no
es sólo llegar a la respuesta correcta, sino
entender realmente lo que está pasando cuando
hacemos operaciones algebraicamente válidas en
cada lado de esta ecuación. Muy bien, entonces
comencemos. Lo primero que mi cerebro quiere hacer
-y hemos hablado de esto antes, hay muchas maneras
diferentes de resolver una ecuación-, pero mi
cerebro quiere simplificar, y lo primero que se ve
un poco peliagudo aquí es este 3 por la expresión
(x + 1), y lo podría simplificar si multiplico 3
por x y 3 por 1, y si hago eso obtengo 3 x + 3
- x = 9, y entonces la clave aquí es que el lado
izquierdo de la segunda ecuación es equivalente
al lado izquierdo de la ecuación superior, y si el
lado izquierdo de la ecuación superior es igual a
9, bueno, entonces el lado izquierdo de esta ecuación
inferior va a ser igual a 9 también. Otra forma de
pensar en esto es que si toda la ecuación superior
es verdadera, toda la ecuación inferior debe ser
verdadera y viceversa, pero sigamos adelante.
Entonces, ¿qué es lo siguiente que podríamos hacer
aquí?, ¿por lo menos podría tratar de simplificar
más el lado izquierdo? Bueno, mi cerebro
inmediatamente ve que tengo 3x aquí y luego
quiero quitarle 1x justo aquí, así que si tengo
3x y luego quito 1x, ¿cuántas x me quedan? Bueno,
me quedan 2x, y todavía tengo este + 3 = 9. Una
vez más, esta expresión izquierda es equivalente
a esta expresión izquierda y es equivalente a esta
expresión superior izquierda, y si alguna de estas
ecuaciones es verdadera, eso debe significar
que todas estas ecuaciones son verdaderas;
pero podríamos seguir adelante. Ahora lo siguiente
que me gustaría hacer es aislar los términos x
en un lado, así que en el lado izquierdo sólo
quiero tener estas 2x. La forma de hacerlo es
que tendría que restar 3 del lado izquierdo, pero
como sabemos cualquier cosa que sumemos o restemos
o multipliquemos o dividamos en un lado de la
ecuación lo tenemos que hacer al otro lado de
la ecuación, así que restaré 3 justo aquí. ¿Y por
qué esto tiene sentido? Bueno, si 2x + 3 realmente
es igual a 9, entonces si resto 3 de 2 x + 3, si
sólo quito 3 ya no será necesariamente igual a 9,
así que tengo que quitar 3 del 9 para que la
equivalencia de ambos lados de la ecuación
sea verdadera. ¿Y qué consigo? Bueno, 3 - 3 se
cancelan y en el lado izquierdo sólo me queda 2x,
y en el lado derecho tengo que es igual a 9 - 3
es igual a 6. Lo sigo enfatizando porque realmente ese
es el punto de este video: que 2x = 6 es una
ecuación equivalente a 3x + 1 - x = 9. Hemos
podido mantener la igualdad porque hemos realizado
estas operaciones algebraicamente válidas,
y podemos decir si 2x = 6 entonces sabemos que
3x + 1 - x = 9, y si esta ecuación superior es
verdadera entonces también sabemos que esta última
ecuación es verdadera. Pero ahora estamos en la
recta final, ¿qué podemos hacer para resolver
x? Bueno, si sólo queremos aislar una x aquí
en el lado izquierdo, como puedes imaginar,
podemos dividir el lado izquierdo entre 2;
pero si dividimos el lado izquierdo entre 2,
tenemos que dividir el lado derecho entre 2 para
mantener esta igualdad. Un dato para recordar:
el término ecuación proviene de una palabra de
latín que significa igualdad: si multiplicamos,
dividimos, sumamos o restamos en un lado, entonces
tenemos que hacerlo del otro lado. Y así nos
quedamos con x = 6 / 2, x = 3. Lo hemos resuelto:
realmente x = 3 sigue siendo una ecuación, y
entonces la ecuación x = 3 va a ser verdadera
si esta ecuación superior es verdadera, y esta
ecuación superior será verdadera si la ecuación
x = 3 es verdadera. Ahora déjenme terminar
con un reto interesante. Si tengo 5x = 6x,
esto se parece a este último paso que tuvimos
aquí, y podríamos pensar "¿Por qué no dividimos
ambos lados entre un factor común? Entonces
quizás podríamos dividir ambos lados entre x,
porque esto es 5 por x y esto es 6 por x". Si hacemos esto,¿qué obtendríamos? A ver, obtendríamos 5 = 6,
que claramente no es igual a 6. Pero ¿qué acaba
de pasar aquí?, ¿es el hecho de que 5x nunca
podría ser igual a 6x? Aunque hicimos operaciones
algebraicamente válidas, tenemos 5 = 6, ¿o hicimos
algo mal? Pausa este video y piénsalo. Bueno,
algunos de ustedes podrían haberse dado cuenta
que si x es un número arbitrario distinto de 0
y lo sabemos, podríamos dividir entre x. Pero ¿y
si x es 0? Si x = 0 no podemos dividir entre 0. Y
eso es lo que está pasando aquí, porque si hacemos
operaciones algebraicamente válidas, en realidad
vemos que este es un caso donde x tendría que ser
igual a 0. Así que déjenme reescribirlo: esto es
5x = 6x, a pesar de que se parece mucho a este
último paso que tuvimos en la primera ecuación y
estemos tentados inmediatamente a dividir en una
especie de reflejo, debemos darnos cuenta de que
tenemos un término de x en ambos lados. Déjenme
combinarlos. Así que podría restar 5x de ambos
lados o podría restar 6x de ambos lados. Déjenme
restar 5x de los dos lados a ver qué pasa: del
lado izquierdo tenemos 5x - 5x = 0, y luego esto
es igual a 6x - 5x = x, entonces obtenemos la
solución para esa ecuación original: 5x = 6x,
y de hecho x = 0. Así que el gran aprendizaje
es apreciar la equivalencia de estas ecuaciones,
si realizamos operaciones algebraicamente válidas.
Y espero que empiecen a tener un sentido intuitivo
de por qué ciertas operaciones son válidas
y por qué otras operaciones no son válidas,
pero si hacemos operaciones válidas realmente
cada paso de la solución, cada una de esas
ecuaciones es equivalente a las ecuaciones
anteriores: si una de ellas es verdadera,
las otras son verdaderas, pero si hacemos una
operación algebraicamente inválida -como dividir
entre x cuando x podría ser igual a 0-, entonces
podríamos comenzar a encontrarnos con problemas.